well there's been systematically growth
in in processing power in semiconductors
you know it is Moore's law at one point
eight improvements of times improvement
for every two years i think is about
what the rate is and we've we used to
fill up an entire entire room with
what's now in your pocket so there's
been just remarkable ability to to
crunch data and of course the
interconnectivity that's been created
because of the internet all of these
things are converging and it creates
just massive paradigm shifts and
capabilities that heretofore didn't
exist but on the point of bottlenecks
and I think this is one of the things
that people need to understand generally
is that that regulation creates massive
bottlenecks there's you know several
areas obviously financial markets
capital markets are highly regularly
regulated and one of the things that I
am very passionate about is getting
capital into the hands of entrepreneurs
because I believe that if you you have
to fund scientists and engineers and put
entrepreneurship together with capital
in order to solve the major problems the
next generation and those are things
like global warming renewable energy
these things are tough problems and they
have to be financed and one of the
things that has occurred is that because
of major shifts in regulation over the
years we compromised the initial public
offering market in the United States so
we used to do literally 500 IPOs a year
based on a smaller economy back in the
early 1990s before the dot-com bubble
and today since the dot since 2000 when
the dot-com bubble ended we've averaged
165 corporate I POS we did a paper for
the organization of Economic Cooperation
and Development the OECD we estimated
that we should be doing 900 IPOs a year
if we hadn't changed market structure
that was a regulatory ship so if you
think about it all this great technology
but it's not helping yet capital to get
into the hands of entrepreneurs you know
two other examples of bottlenecks in
totally different industries would be
obviously fossil fuel development you're
concerned about the environment health
care
personalized medicine and the ability to
mine patient records obviously those
concerns about privacy and so anytime
there is a concern just like in capital
markets about investor protections there
tends to be a level of inertia that's
driven by regulators pharmaceutical
development biotechnology for example
you have clinical trials and and so if
we could do things ultimately to remove
these bottlenecks which is one of the
things we've worked on in capital
markets we think we can usher in a great
new era of of innovation and achievement
and drive some of these exponential
improvements if you will in other areas
of the economy not simply in technology
it's interesting because when I was down
in Congress I was asked you know by by
the Republicans to say that there was
too much regulation and I was asked by
the Democrats to say that there was too
little regulation and I what I like to
say is I don't think that there's enough
enlightened regulation you need
regulation just like you need traffic's
traffic lights or a form of regulation
of if we didn't have traffic lights
people would kill each other by going to
intersections in this particular
instance though the regulation that we
need on the one hand has to be
respectful of investors but it can't be
the kind of the nanny state and on the
other hand that has to give make it more
more effective and efficient for
entrepreneurs and their representatives
to raise capital to get America back to
business I I believe that the Delta
between what we've done in the way of
IPOs and what we should do which is the
difference between 165 IPOs and 900 IPOs
a year is worth about 10 million jobs to
the US economy over the course of a
decade that is your job problem in the
United States and it's something that we
clearly can fix by changing market
structure so that it benefits smaller
companies and the development of an
ecosystem to support those smaller
companies most job growth in the United
States occurs in small companies not
large companies and there's actual data
from the Brookings Institute that
actually shows that the rate of rate of
creation of small companies has actually
been in secular long-term
decline in the United States so those
are the kinds of trends that we
ultimately want to want to reverse my
company issue works is actually focused
on marketing creating technologies to
better market securities we effectively
want to create the future of securities
marketing why is that important it's
important because we've got plenty of
capital out there what we have is an
inability for small companies to reach
the right pockets of capital to cut the
amount of wear and tear there is on
management so that the management teams
which are very skinny in small
entrepreneurial companies can actually
devote their time to the development of
their their new technologies and their
new businesses and I think that if we
can take that bottleneck if you will out
of management's hands and effectively
remove it using technology better turbo
charging the marketing if you will so
that the right ideas get to the right
investors more quickly we're all going
to be better off